Hey reactors, Trace here for a DNews short.
If you're a regular watcher of DNews you know
nuclear reactors come in two flavors -- fission
and fusion.
Fission is about breaking atoms apart to release
energy.
Fusion is about squishing atoms together to
release energy.
"Nuclear power" is fission, but we really
wanna figure out this fusion thing.
It's better.
In December 2015, a new fusion reactor was
tested and it's more efficient than any before
it -- the Wendelstein 7-X stellarator.
It even sounds cool… oh, and it looks like
a donut.
A variety of fusion reactors have been proposed,
with mixed levels of success.
Tokamaks and Stellarators seem to be the best
way forward.
Though they’re very different designs, at
their core, they both create magnetic fields
to contain donuts of this superheated plasma.
The stellarator is less popular because they're
tougher to build; it took 19 years to construct
the W-7X but once it turned on, it briefly
contained plasma at "80 million degrees centigrade
for a quarter of a second."
Unfortunately, 80 million degrees isn't quite
enough to mimic what we think happens inside
the sun.
The sun is fueled by the fusion of superheated
plasmas of hydrogen that are smushed together
(or fused) inside the sun's core, forming
helium.
If scientists can get the temperature over
100 million degrees celsius, the electrons
of hydrogen would be stripped away, and the
nuclei would smash into each other and fuse…
creating energy.
Hydrogen is the most abundant material in
the universe -- if we can figure out fusion,
we'll have an “almost inexhaustible" source
of energy.
So, this isn't ready yet.
It took more energy to make the flash of plasma
in the stellarator than they got out of it.
But, if they can hit their specifications
and keep it running for 30 minutes… that
could change everything.
The current record?
A French tokamak was on for 6-and-a-half minutes.
We're not there yet, but we're on our way.
If you want to know more about tokamak and
other fusion reactors, check out this video.
Do you have questions?
Comments?
Complaints?
Whatever?
How's things?
Tell us in the comments and please subscribe
for more DNews.